Why don't we talk next to Chris from Ocala?
Is it pronounced Ocala or Ocala, Florida?
Hello? Yes, that's you. Hey, David, what's
up? Yes, it's Ocala, Ocala, Florida.
We're away from Orlando. Got it.
What's going on? Not much so.
First off, I want to say thank you for everything
you do, man. I mean, beforehand before I even saw
your show, I was having a bit of trouble
finding any left leaning talk shows. I
feel like I've been more exposed, like the
people that like Ben Shapiro or Dave Rubin.
And it was really hard finding the opposite.
And when I delve into your channel, I was able
to completely switch my views on everything.
I mean, wow, that made a lot of sense and
everything. And I just want to say thank you for
that pleasure. I question about Biden's age. The
right has been pushing this propaganda that he's
too old and that Kamala Harris is going to take
over and everything. And I know that's a bit
of a stretch, but I mean, at the same time,
I recognize that the guy is 78 years old. Should
I be expecting that something could happen in
the near future? I mean, I know that you said
before that wealthier people tend to live longer,
like with Donald Trump, even though he's severely
obese. I mean, the guy's a freak and, well,
he does have a lot of money. So it's expected
that he'll live a rather long lifespan.
Listen, Joe, so so you're absolutely right. That
class has a huge interaction with life expectancy
in the United States. But I don't know that it's
that different between multimillionaires and
billionaires. So, Joe, but from the standpoint
of economic class, Joe Biden at this point is a
wealthy guy. And I don't think that's really the
issue. You do point out the risk factors. Donald
Trump is quite overweight. Joe Biden is not.
Donald Trump doesn't exercise. We regularly saw
Joe Biden riding his bike. Donald Trump is proud
of eating an unhealthy diet. As far as I know,
Biden's diet is healthier, but Biden is
a few years older. Here's the reality.
When you look at actuarial tables for a 74 year
old and a 78 year old. Sure, the 78 year old on
average is more likely to die in the next year
than the 74 year old by a relatively small margin.
But in both cases, you're talking about
people who are in their mid to late 70s. So
whatever concerns you had about
Donald Trump along these lines
should be sort of similar about Joe Biden and
that maybe the country would be better served
having someone who's not in their mid to late
70s. But I don't know about, you know, if you
were fine with Trump's age and health, I don't see
it being dramatically different with Joe Biden.
Right. OK, so, I mean, like, realistically
speaking, I mean, I shouldn't really be
expecting a President Harris any time soon,
right? I mean, the guy's being taken care of.
Well, listen, he's getting the best health care
anyone can get as president of the United States.
And the problem is we can make assessments
about what we expect from large populations.
Making predictions about any one person's health
is very difficult to do, and that applies to any
any individual. Right. OK. All right, Chris,
I'm going to let you go because your phone
won't stop buzzing in the background and it's
kind of getting to be a little bit irritating
to the audience. So we're going to we're going to
go. But I really do appreciate hearing from you.